[Music]
Netflix is killing it with the perfect
rom-com the next title slated for
release has already caused quite a buzz
online you won't believe which of its
stars face online backlash when they
came out stick around until the end to
see the tweet that got them into hot
water if you want to stay up to date on
Netflix releases and so much more hit
that subscribe button and give us a big
thumbs up
now let's find out the ten things about
Ciera Burgess is a loser Netflix is
trying to hide from you Sierra Burgess
is this story isn't new the plot of
Sierra Burgess is a loser is pretty
straightforward the main character
Sierra is a total outcast
she's bullied by the popular kids for
being plus-sized and brainy Sierra gets
a random text from a guy and begins
flirting she's thrilled to find out the
mystery man is the most popular jock in
school he thinks Sierra is her arch
nemesis cheerleader Veronica Sierra
doesn't reveal who she really is
and Jaime develops a major crush sound
familiar that's probably because the
story has been told many times before
the movies based on the 19th century
play Cyrano de Bergerac that's not the
only place you may have heard this plot
there's also the truth about cats and
dogs too as well as Roxanne both of
those classic rom-coms feature
characters who masquerade as someone
else to win their love there are
countless other tales of love and
mistaken identity it's a popular and
relatable fantasy who hasn't wanted the
chance to tell their crush how they feel
anonymously or I get to know them
without any real risk this version has
plenty of new twists it's set in a
modern high school the lead character is
the girl and we're pretty sure they
didn't have cellphones in 1897 these
modern adaptations give it a unique spin
but the story is hundreds of years old
harmful stereotypes fans have been
buzzing with excitement since the
trailer was released some can't wait to
see Shannon others are there for noah
while the buzz has been mostly positive
some wonder if the film will miss the
mark the movie is meant to be a
feel-good comedy about catfishing and
love it touches on some hot button
issues like bullying body positivity and
standards you are a magnificent piece
for a funny movie these are some serious
topics the takeaway is supposed to be
that you're great just the way you are
it could send the opposite message if
it's not handled carefully in the movies
finding popularity often comes with the
price of your personality it would be
above our to spend the whole film
rooting for Sierra just to see her turn
into someone else fans are hoping Sierra
will prove that the world would accept
you the way you are
if Sierra changes herself to fit in the
meaning is lost the tagline for this
film about pretending to be someone else
says it all just be you will have to
wait until fall to see if Sierra remains
her quirky self one for the boys Noah
synteny yo is such a sweetheart in
interviews he's always so genuine and
open with his feelings it might be easy
to assume Sierra Burgess as a loser is
just a chick flick but fans are in for a
surprise in a recent interview with
build Noah said the film has a lot of
great messages for guys too Noah wants
fans to be unafraid to fall in love for
the first time jamie has the guts to
text Veronica he didn't know he got the
wrong girl but he took that first step
with no fear Noah wants fans to learn
that they can love again after
heartbreak breakups can feel like the
end of the world but Noah hopes he can
help fans move on what a cutie
Noah certainly seems to know a thing or
two about romance we're loving this pure
sweetness Noah says that the film is
meant to show guys the society can't
tell them what they want seeing a young
heartthrob tell young men to love
without fear is heart melting hearing
him encouraged young men to determine
their own beauty standard and ditched
what society tries to sell is pretty
great too this film seems to be brimming
with positive messages and wholesome
themes who knew a movie about catfishing
could be so uplifting you'll have to
wait until the September release to find
out what Jamie decides his definition of
beauty is questionable cousin there are
a lot of differences between this film
and its inspiration the most obvious is
that this time the main character is a
girl a sure
is gonna work Serrano's big nose has
been replaced with modern body issues
one of the biggest changes is how Sierra
knows her crush in the Netflix rom-com
Sierra meets Jaime at school
there's nothing questionable about one
teenager noticing another is kind of
cute the original play however wasn't so
innocent in the 1897 play the object of
Serrano's infection is his distant
cousin times were slightly different
then it wasn't uncommon for distant
cousins to marry to keep wealth and
property within a family Sierra didn't
live in 1897 and she certainly isn't
going to be married off to save the
family farm to adapt the story for a
modern audience with modern morals this
just would not work even distant cousins
are still taboo crushes now it's much
easier for people to travel to get in
touch these days so he casts much
broader Nets the play is over 120 years
old the rules of dating are nearly
indistinguishable now flowers are for
formal occasions relationships can last
years before anyone pops the question
and no one dates their cousin to an
audience in 1897 a couple being
distantly related would be a nothing
Shannon purser is actually gorgeous it
seems like every other teen movie has a
huge makeover scene movies like The
Princess Diaries and she's all that
seemed to tell us that every misfit is a
new haircut and wardrobe away from
popularity Hollywood has long been
criticized for putting so much emphasis
on a very narrow definition of beauty
even when a character is described as
ugly a glamorous actor is cast and
dressed down after all American Ferrera
is stunning in and out of her role on
Ugly Betty putting glasses on an old wig
on a beautiful actor is an outdated
trope in the trailer we don't see a lot
of conscious efforts to make Ciara
intentionally unattractive that choice
is really refreshing it shifts the blame
for why her character is an outcast off
of her and onto her judgmental peers and
meant looking at you makes me want to
gouge my eyes out Ciara is presented as
natural and quirky her classmates reject
her for being plus-sized bookish and not
fitting their idea of prettiness the
film chooses to focus on the cruelty and
unfairness of those standards rather
than trying to sell us an ugly lead
that's a wise choice as actors
Shannon courser is absolutely adorable
it's hard to imagine her being picked on
until you remember our culture's
obsession with
this strawberry blonde freckled actor
was born in Georgia ironically she has a
cute peaches and cream complexion to
honor her home state casting purser was
a genius smooth as she perfectly
demonstrates that not all beauties fit
the mold embarrassingly fans may
recognize Noah Santonio from his work in
to all the boys I've loved before this
Florida native has taken the acting
world by storm and shot to stardom
almost overnight his Instagram followers
hit six digits very shortly after Noah's
career took off he experienced a major
online embarrassment it's used the
heartthrob is a bit of a batboy photo
surfaced online of the actor that were a
little scandalous he appeared to have
too much to drink and was shockingly
missing his clothes minivan the photos
to be risque but an example of harmless
fun gone too far
others were happy to see a new side of
the romantic Idol in a recent BuzzFeed
video Noah described himself as a
sentimental sweetheart and fans ate it
up the leaked photos shook that image
but many seem amused if the images
weren't enough of a scandal there was
also an embarrassing video in the two
minute clip no appears to be describing
a racy scenario it's unclear who the
video was meant for but it was plainly
intended to be private the source of
these leaks is unconfirmed while many
fans were shocked by the spicy side of
the sweet actor none seemed to be too
offended the contents may have been
embarrassing but it was mostly harmless
Noah meant for both the photo and the
video to remain private but now there's
no going back his antics are now part of
his public reputation surprise
soundtrack appearance lots of people
know that Shannon is a talented actress
her character barb on stranger things
left our hearts totally broken
there are barb t-shirts out there for
her loyal followers we have even gotten
barbed tattoos
those who follow Shannon on social media
may know she has many talents the actor
released a video of herself belting out
a Frank Ocean tune fans were thrilled to
learn that Shannon had such an
incredible singing voice actor Debbie
Ryan commented that she was shaken and
asked Shannon to song often this was the
first hint anyone had that Shannon had
these pipes many still have no idea
fans you catch Ciara Burgess is a loser
are in for a treat
not only does Shannon star in the film
but she also sings a song on the
soundtrack what her song sounds like is
still a mystery as the soundtrack will
be released with the film since not
everyone knows about Shannon's beautiful
voice we imagine the song will be a fun
surprise for a lot of viewers
Shannon's song is called sunflower if
you follow her on Instagram you'll
notice the yellow blossoms on her
profile we're willing to bet it will pop
up at a big part of the movie it's not
often that a star is on the soundtrack
outside of a musical Jamie isn't a
typical jock you're more than just a hot
jock are you thinking
teen movies are often full of
stereotypes the popular Mean Girl the
brainy nerd and of course the meathead
jocks every character is a cartoonish
meme there doesn't seem to be any of
that in Sierra Burgess as a loser when
interviewed about his character Noah
said he's smart and emotionally aware
he's a deep soulful thinker Noah
describes his character as having a more
worldly perspective he's even said he
can be goofy how many movies feature a
popular football player who's smart and
emotionally mature usually high school
footballers are portrayed as having
anger problems and failing grades this
real character is a fresh change of pace
watching the sensitive and intelligent
Jamie fall for strong Ciara is sure to
be a lot of fun Noah is the perfect
rom-com Lee because he portrays guys as
we all want to know in real life if you
were hoping for a corny film about the
same old characters you've seen before
this movie isn't for you just in time
for the back-to-school season Ciara
Burgess is a loser is sure to be a big
hit the phone calls weren't acting the
entire film is about Jamie mistakenly
texting Ciara we see the pair eventually
move on to phone conversations the
trailer is full of lines taken from what
appear to be late-night chats these
teams are huge for the film that's how
Jamie and Ciara fall in love in an
interview with ET Noah revealed a
production secret every time we see his
character on the phone with Ciara the
actors were actually on a live phone
call he also said that he and Shannon
shared a true connection when asked how
it was to work with her Noah called
Shannon real and presence he expressed
quite a lot of admiration for his
co-star Noah said that the phone calls
were genuine not acting could it be that
the actors got to know each other and
even began to develop feelings while
they filmed it wouldn't be the first
time co-stars developed a crush on each
other
Noah himself has been surrounded by
rumors with a
costar after his breakout role in to all
the boys I've loved before everyone
thought he was dating his co-star mana
Connor their on-screen and onset
chemistry was adorable the two were
photographed napping on set they've had
matching profile pics on Instagram
unfortunately for hopeful shippers
everywhere Lana already has a boyfriend
could his flirty past have repeated
itself with Shannon Twitter faux pas
Shannon is no stranger to social media
her Instagram has over eight hundred and
thirty thousand followers the Riverdale
actress found herself accidentally
offending fans when she took to Twitter
to defend a certain scene the problem
was many fans saw the scene as
misleading and using the LGBTQ community
the moment in question featured two
female characters exchanging a kiss it
was used heavily in teasers and promos
leading up to the premiere of the show
many fans were upset that the full scene
was two girls pretending to kiss for
attention which many saw as a missed
opportunity for LGBTQ a representation
fans were hoping there was a meaningful
relationship behind the smooch they saw
not just attention seeking antics
Shannon tweeted that fans who shipped
Betty and Veronica shouldn't be hateful
when they found out there was no couple
Shannon didn't realize the full weight
of why at the scene had upset so many
fans reached out to her to explain why
the promo clips were such a big deal
Shannon heard them out and apologized
once she understood why the issue seemed
so sensitive Shannon decided to share
something with fans in a screenshot of a
note shannon revealed that she is a
member of the LGBTQ community she
admitted that she's still working out
what that means for her she also
explained that she hadn't expected to
hurt anyone and realized why fans would
be happy to see Betty and Veronica as a
couple we hope you enjoyed finding out
what Netflix doesn't want you to know
about Ciera Burgess is a loser we'll see
you later
[Music]